we began with a political blockbuster
tonight presidential attorney Rudy
Giuliani says special counsel Robert
Muller is promising to follow Justice
Department guidance that a sitting
president cannot be indicted this
obviously has implications for the
Russia collusion probe and may come as a
seismic disappointment to some of
President Trump's critics chief White
House correspondent John Roberts starts
us off with the breaking details tonight
from the North Lawn good evening John
Brandt good evening to you I spoke with
Rudy Giuliani on the telephone in the
last hour and he confirmed that Fox News
dat about two weeks ago the Special
Counsel Robert Muller assured the
president's outside legal team that he
would follow DOJ guidelines that a
sitting president cannot be indicted
Giuliani says that Muller doesn't really
have any choice he has to follow the the
findings of a 1999 Clinton era DOJ memo
now that's not to say that Muller still
couldn't find some evidence of
wrongdoing that Congress could act on
but the president's legal team doesn't
appear concerned Giuliani telling Fox
News a short time ago quote this case is
essentially over they're just in denial